good morning Hank it's Tuesday today's
video is about weird things that can
happen so I went to Kenyon College in
Gambier Ohio Kenyon is like Hogwarts
except with fewer Death Eaters and more
corn I was an undistinguished student
but I was smart enough to surround
myself with very smart people like Bruce
with whom I would eventually spend a
disastrous summer in Moose Pass Alaska
and Mary Fran who would later get
married inside an elephant so Mary Fran
and Bruce decided they wanted to read
James Joyce's Ulysses together for an
independent study and asked me if I
would join them and since I liked the
professor and also figured a class about
a single book couldn't be that hard I
agreed we were joined by a precocious
sophomore named Randy who was taking
this picture so needs to be photoshopped
in perfect and then together we learned
just how hard a class about a single
book could be Hank I spent more time on
my final paper in that class than I did
on anything else in college except
possibly trying to get girls to make out
with me and I remember everybody's paper
I wrote about nationalism Mary Fran
wrote about Molly bloom Bruce wrote
about this potato that was inside blooms
pocket for much of the book and Randy
wrote about religious deconstructionism
model it was very complicated we all
became very close in that class and it
was the first time I ever felt
academically grown up like this was back
in the days when I thought that
adulthood would basically consist of
having a series of very interesting
conversations about great books it turns
out that adulthood primarily consists of
standing in line and being on hold but
yeah so I graduated from college
thinking I would become an Episcopal
minister Mary Fran went off to law
school Randy went off to film school and
Bruce went off to become a musician
after I decided not to go to Divinity
School I got some writing jobs including
one working for Mental Floss and then I
was in a position where I had to hire a
freelance writer and I remembered that
Randy was pretty good at you know
explaining things simply so I hired him
but he still wanted to make movies I
left Mental Floss for the world of young
adult novels Bruce now reports for the
NPR show the world and Mary Fran having
become a lawyer heroically abandoned the
law in favor of librarianship god I love
librarians all the while Randy and I
stayed friends and eventually he started
uploading his weird little documentaries
to YouTube where they became extremely
popular because they are amazing and
then one day he told me he was working
on a novel based on thousands of found
photographs he's collected by then Randy
Riggs was going by his real name ransom
Riggs and he sent me his finished book
miss Peregrine's Home for peculiar
children and I thought that it was weird
and wonderful and quite unlike anything
I had ever read but even so Hank I kept
trying to lower his expectations because
a lot of books come out every week by
then I had published four novels of my
own and a couple
of them made it to the New York Times
bestseller list but two of them had sold
less than a hundred copies in their
first weeks in print I've seen great
books get lost in crowded bookstores
over and over again and I kept telling
ransom it's a marathon not a sprint your
first novel isn't your last novel bla
bla bla bla bla
it was an instant bestseller a few
months later the fall of our stars came
out and next week amazingly our books
will be number one and number two on the
New York Times bestseller list so hey
that's nice and funny and weird but it's
not the real story professional lives
which take turns you can never imagine
from lawyer to librarian or from
minister to vlogger are important but
it's not what life is about human life
is really about relationships and
communities and I think of my friendship
with Randi I don't think of this
although it's cool I think of us driving
to the Grand Canyon with our friend
Kathy I think of driving through the
snow in Ohio and the endlessness of
Texas and watching the Sun Rise creep up
the walls of the Grand Canyon he's taken
pictures I made it and then I think of
his 12 years later walking around Los
Angeles together still taking pictures
what a blessing Hank I'll see you on
Friday